This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us. That's why L'Oreal Group has built a business that is inclusive at its heart with 100% of its brands, championing diversity. With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women, diversity is a strength that helps L'Oreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit L'Oreal.com to learn more.
本期节目由欧莱雅集团赞助播出。美是一种推动我们前进的强大力量。正因如此，欧莱雅集团建立了一项以包容为核心的业务，其旗下100%的品牌都致力于倡导多元化。欧莱雅集团在全球为30岁以下人群提供了25,000个职业机会，且54%的管理职位由女性担任，多元化已成为欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最佳美容产品的力量源泉。访问L'Oreal.com了解更多信息。
Many of us go through our days surrounded by other people, yet we often keep to ourselves. We sit next to someone on a train heading to work, but keep our earbuds in and spend the ride scrolling on our phone. Or we engage in some chit chat with a colleague or a new acquaintance, but stop short of a real conversation. These moments may seem small, but they matter more than you think. Psychologist's research shows that even brief social interactions, talking to a string, stranger passing on a compliment, can boost our mood and enrich our life in significant ways. And yet, we hesitate. We assume that other people aren't interested in talking, that a deeper conversation would
我们许多人在日常生活中都被人群包围，却往往保持着独处。我们坐在上班的火车上，身边坐着人，却戴着耳机，一路刷着手机。或者我们与同事或新结识的人闲聊几句，却点到为止，没有进行真正的交流。这些时刻看似微不足道，但它们的重要性超乎你的想象。心理学研究表明，即使是短暂的社交互动，比如与陌生人交谈或随口夸赞一句，也能显著改善我们的情绪并丰富我们的生活。然而，我们却犹豫不决。我们认为别人对交谈不感兴趣，认为深入的交谈会
feel awkward, or that our kind words won't matter. So why are we so often unsocial avoiding connections that could make us happier? What gets in the way of reaching out to others and what happens when we do? How accurate are our assumptions of how other people will receive? respond to us. And as we're increasingly communicating through screens, what kinds of interactions actually help us feel less alone? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Nicholas Epley, the John Templeton Keller Distinguished Service
让人感到尴尬，或者认为我们的善意之言无足轻重。那么，为什么我们经常表现得不爱社交，回避那些本可以让我们更快乐的联系呢？是什么阻碍了我们与他人接触？当我们主动接触时又会发生什么？我们对他人如何回应我们的假设有多准确？随着我们越来越多地通过屏幕进行交流，什么样的互动才能真正帮助我们减少孤独感？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是尼古拉斯·埃普利博士，他是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的约翰·坦普尔顿·凯勒杰出服务
Professor of Behavioral Science at the University of Chicago Booth School of Business. He studies social cognition and why people so routinely misunderstand each other. His research has been published in more than two dozen academic journals and has been featured in the New York Times, The Wall Street Journal, CNN and NPR, among many other outlets. His new book, published in May, is called A Little More Social, How Small Choices Can Create Unexpected Happiness, Health, and Connection. Dr. Epley, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much, Kim.
行为科学教授。他研究社会认知，以及为什么人们总是习惯性地误解彼此。他的研究成果已发表在二十多家学术期刊上，并被《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、CNN和NPR等众多媒体报道。他于五月出版的新书名为《多一点社交：微小的选择如何创造意想不到的快乐、健康与联系》。埃普利博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢，金。
That was a fabulous introduction. I appreciate that. Speaking of introductions, in your book introduction, you wrote that a simple moment that most of us have probably experienced, deciding whether to talk to a stranger on a train, sparked this entire line of research for you. Tell us that story. So one of the great things about being a psychologist is we get to look outside the window and notice what's happening in the world, wonder what the heck is going on and try to actually answer the question scientifically. And I had one of those moments one morning when I was commuting into the University of Chicago, which I do every day. I've done for the last 20 years. We live on the far south side of Chicago. University of Chicago is in Hyde Park. And I sat down that morning.
那是一段精彩的介绍，我很感激。说到介绍，在您的书序言中，您写道，我们大多数人都可能经历过的一个简单时刻——决定是否在火车上与陌生人交谈——激发了您整个研究方向。请给我们讲讲那个故事。作为一名心理学家，最棒的事情之一就是我们可以观察窗外，注意世界上正在发生的事情，好奇到底发生了什么，并尝试用科学的方法回答这个问题。有一天早上，我在通勤去芝加哥大学的路上，就像我过去20年每天做的那样，我有了这样的时刻。我们住在芝加哥远南区，芝加哥大学在海德公园。那天早上我坐了下来。
I was writing a chapter from my first book, mind-wise, at the time. So that was all going through my head. I was writing the chapter on how we're highly social creatures made happier and healthier by reaching out and connecting with each other. And I had this sort of eureka moment, just minutes after I'd sat down on the train, that here we all were, highly social creatures, now sitting hip-to-hip with another highly social creature. made happier and healthier.
当时我正在写我的第一本书《思维智慧》中的一章。所以这些想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋。我正在写的那一章是关于我们如何成为高度社会化的生物，通过接触和与他人建立联系而变得更快乐、更健康。就在我在火车上坐下几分钟后，我突然产生了一种“尤里卡”时刻：我们所有人都是高度社会化的生物，现在正与另一个高度社会化的生物肩并肩坐着，本可以变得更快乐、更健康。
And none of us said a word. I mean, you could have heard a pin drop. It was totally silent. And a woman sat down next to me that morning, who I'll never forget. She was, I'm, I was about 35 at the time. I'm betting she was probably about 50. African-American woman,
但我们谁也没说话。我的意思是，当时安静得连根针掉在地上都能听见。那天早上，一位女士坐在我旁边，我永远不会忘记她。我当时大约35岁，我敢打赌她大概50岁左右。一位非裔美国女性，
dressed professionally for work, wearing just this killer red hat. And I decided that, you know, I'm going to put myself in an experiment this morning. I'm going to try something different and just see what happens. So, you know, I kind of worked at my courage a little bit because I had, you know, this voice shouting at me that this is going to be weird and awkward and
穿着职业装，戴着一顶超级好看的红帽子。我决定，你知道吗，今天早上我要把自己放进一个实验里。我要尝试一些不同的东西，看看会发生什么。所以，你知道，我鼓起了一点勇气，因为我脑子里有个声音在对我大喊：这会很奇怪、很尴尬，
she'll think I'm a creep or whatever, all these reasons not to connect. And instead, I turned to her and I said, hi, my name's Nick, I love your hat. I have one just like it. And she laughed kind of like you did, Kim. She turned to me. And then we just started talking. And, you know, the next 30 minutes unfolded really easily. I mean, we went from one topic to another. We found things we had in common. I wouldn't have guessed. She had kids. I had kids talking about her families, kind of encountering some challenges with the kids of different varieties. And she was talking about what she wanted out of her future in her job. She was feeling kind of stuck at the moment. And the time just went by really quickly. When I got up to leave, she kind of held my wrist
她会觉得我是个怪人，或者诸如此类，所有这些不该去联系的理由。相反，我转向她说：“嗨，我叫尼克，我很喜欢你的帽子。我有一顶一模一样的。”她笑了，就像你刚才那样，金。她转向我。然后我们就开始聊天了。你知道，接下来的30分钟过得非常轻松。我们从一个话题聊到另一个话题。我们发现了一些共同点。我之前根本没猜到。她有孩子，我也有孩子，我们谈论了各自的家庭，谈论了在抚养孩子过程中遇到的各种挑战。她还谈到了她对未来工作的期望，当时她觉得有点迷茫。时间过得非常快。当我起身离开时，她抓住了我的手腕，
and just briefly, and she said, thank you so much for taking the time to talk with me this morning. And, you know, all the details by this point have kind of faded out of my mind of exactly what we talked about. But it left me with such a distinct feeling, not just that, that was good, but that it was surprisingly good. In my entire career up to that point, I've been misunderstanding, I've been studying rather, how people misunderstand each other's minds, how we make mistaken inferences about what's going on between our ears. And it struck me that this moment right here might be precisely one of those moments. And if I wasn't the only one on that train, who was thinking this conversation to be more awkward and weird and less pleasant than it actually
只是短暂地，她说：“非常感谢你今天早上花时间和我聊天。”你知道，到目前为止，我们具体谈了什么细节已经从我的脑海中淡去了。但它给我留下了一种非常独特的感觉，不仅仅是“那次交谈很好”，而是“好得令人惊讶”。在我职业生涯的整个过程中，我一直在研究人们如何误解彼此的思想，我们如何对彼此脑子里在想什么做出错误的推断。我突然意识到，此刻可能正是其中一个时刻。如果火车上不止我一个人认为这种交谈会比实际情况更尴尬、更奇怪、更不愉快，
was, then we're kind of all making a mistake on that train. And if it's not just happening there, but in lots of other places, then that would change how I live my life. And, you know, a single anecdote is not data. It's just, you know, an experience, right? So we're going to get a little serious with this. We're going to run an actual experiment. So that's what we did. But that morning, that morning fundamentally changed my career. Put us on a different trajectory than I had been on before. So to broaden out this whole concept, the central finding of your research is that people systematically underestimate how much they're going to enjoy all different kinds of social interactions. Why do we so consistently get this wrong? There are surely lots of things. These
那么我们所有人都在火车上犯了一个错误。如果这种情况不仅发生在那里，而且发生在许多其他地方，那将改变我的生活方式。而且，你知道，一个轶事不是数据。它只是一个经历，对吧？所以我们要认真对待这件事。我们要进行一个真正的实验。这就是我们所做的。但那天早上，那个早晨从根本上改变了我的职业生涯。让我们走上了一条与之前不同的轨道。那么，为了拓宽这个概念，您研究的核心发现是，人们系统性地低估了他们会从各种社交互动中获得多少乐趣。为什么我们总是会犯这种错误？肯定有很多原因。这些
effects are often very, very large. A typical effect sizes in psychology that we deal with are on the order of a third of a standard deviation between the means of two conditions. These are often two to three. standard deviations, difference between the means, these are huge effects. So there are lots of things going on, and I won't suggest we've understood them all comprehensively, but we've pursued at least three that I think are important. One is that we have two minds here, and if I am evaluating the situation differently from the person I'm reaching out to, then I run the risk of misunderstanding how somebody would respond to me. So that morning on the train, for instance, I was all worried about what am I going to say to this
效应通常非常非常大。心理学中我们处理的典型效应量大约是两个条件均值之间标准差的三分之一。而这些通常是两到三个标准差，均值之间的差异，这些都是巨大的效应。所以有很多因素在起作用，我不会说我们已经全面理解了它们，但我们至少研究了三个我认为很重要的因素。第一，我们这里有两个头脑，如果我评估情况的方式与我接触的人不同，那么我就冒着误解别人会如何回应我的风险。比如那天早上在火车上，我一直在担心我要对这个人说什么，
person, right? Like, I'm, you know, I don't even have an opening line to start with that's any good, right? And that is pretty characteristic of how we think about ourselves, which is in terms of our competency. We're agents. We're doing stuff. We got to figure out, you know, what am I going to do to be successful in this thing? And so we think a lot about our competency. When you enter into conversation, you sit down to write somebody a gratitude letter. You think about giving somebody a compliment. You, you contemplate being open and honest in your relationship in some conversation. You know, all these opportunities we have to reach out and connect. You're thinking about, am I going to be able to do this well? The person you're reaching out to, though, is much more interested in how nice are you,
对吧？就像，我甚至没有一句好的开场白，对吧？这很能代表我们思考自己的方式，即从我们的能力角度出发。我们是行动者。我们在做事。我们必须弄清楚，我该怎么做才能在这件事上取得成功？所以我们想了很多关于我们能力的问题。当你开始交谈，你坐下来给某人写感谢信。你考虑给某人一个赞美。你考虑在某种谈话中保持开放和诚实。你知道，我们所有这些接触和联系的机会。你都在想，我能做好这件事吗？然而，你接触的那个人更关心你有多友善，
how kind are you, how trustworthy, honest are you, are you somebody who is friendly or are you a scary person I should avoid? They're interested in your warmth, which is another fundamental dimension we evaluate people on and other people just care more about our warmth. And so if we reach out to somebody in a warm, friendly kind way, but we're worried about our competence. We're likely to underestimate how positively the other person's going to respond right away. That's one. The other thing is, and second thing, is that social interaction is dynamic. It goes back and forth. There's reciprocity and responsiveness, right? It doesn't just go anywhere. It mostly goes in one direction, and social interactions have some magnetic qualities to them that pull us together. Reciprocity is a big one.
你有多善良，多值得信赖，多诚实，你是一个友好的人，还是一个我应该避开的可怕的人？他们关心你的温暖，这是我们评估人的另一个基本维度，而其他人确实更关心我们的温暖。所以，如果我们以一种温暖、友好的方式接触某人，但我们却在担心自己的能力，我们很可能会低估对方会立即做出多么积极的回应。这是第一点。第二点是，社交互动是动态的。它是有来有往的。有互惠和响应，对吧？它不会随处发生。它大多朝着一个方向发展，社交互动具有某种磁性，将我们拉在一起。互惠是一个很大的因素。
If I reach out and say hello to you, Kim, what do you normally do? Do you, back to me. You say hi, right? I smile at you. You normally smile back at me. I reach out to you in a positive way to start a friendly conversation. Typically, that's the direction the conversation goes. There's reciprocity. And so, you know, when we enter a conversation or we enter an interaction, we kind of imagine that the things could go kind of any direction, right? Negative, positive. Real social interaction, though, is constrained. And in our research, we find over and over again that people don't really take those dynamic properties of social interaction into account. They're very hard to simulate in our minds, how a conversation is going to go back or forth,
如果我主动向你打招呼，金，你通常会怎么做？你会回应我。你说嗨，对吧？我向你微笑。你通常会回我微笑。我以积极的方式向你伸出援手，开始一场友好的谈话。通常，谈话就是朝着那个方向发展的。这就是互惠。所以，你知道，当我们进入一场谈话或互动时，我们有点想象事情可能会朝着任何方向发展，对吧？消极的，积极的。然而，真正的社交互动是受限的。在我们的研究中，我们一次又一次地发现，人们并没有真正考虑到社交互动的这些动态属性。在我们的脑海中模拟一场谈话将如何来回进行，
how you're going to be responsive to what I'm saying, how you're going to reciprocate an action. And as a result, we tend to think that more outcomes are possible and actually are an underestimate on average how well these things will go. And if we have those two seeds of pessimism already planted in our minds that nudge us in a direction that might make us overly negative, then this third one, I think, will help maintain it. Pessimism, it turns out, is self-fulfilling in a way that optimism isn't.
你将如何回应我所说的话，你将如何回馈一个行动，是非常困难的。结果，我们倾向于认为更多的结果是可能的，而实际上平均低估了这些事情会进行得多么顺利。如果我们脑子里已经种下了那两颗悲观的种子，促使我们朝着可能让我们过于消极的方向发展，那么我认为这第三点将有助于维持它。事实证明，悲观在某种程度上是自我实现的，而乐观则不然。
So if I'm, you know, doubtful about how, you know, whether you want to talk to me or how positively you'll respond if I pass along a compliment or express my gratitude to you or ask for help from you, any of these phenomena that we've studied, if I'm somewhat pessimistic,
所以，如果我怀疑你是否想和我说话，或者如果我传达赞美、表达感激或寻求帮助时你会做出多么积极的回应，任何我们研究过的这些现象，如果我有点悲观，
then I probably won't try. I won't start a conversation. I won't ask you something meaningful about yourself. I won't ask for help when I need it. And in turn, I won't find out that I might be wrong. Optimism gets calibrated. Pessimism just doesn't. And I think those three things together,
那么我可能就不会尝试。我不会开始谈话。我不会问你关于你自己的有意义的事情。我需要帮助时也不会寻求帮助。反过来，我也就不会发现我可能错了。乐观是可以校准的。而悲观则不然。我认为这三点加在一起，
that's probably not going to explain all of our over-relectance to reach out and engage with other people, but I think it explains a big chunk because it plants doubts in our mind, and it's those doubts that drive our choices. What are some other examples of the different kinds of interactions you've studied where participants have thought, I'm not going to enjoy that or that's going to be really awkward? But then they found it more rewarding than they expected. So the clearest example of this goes beyond just conversations with random people to get to know them a little bit. But conversations that really connect us with other people, kinds of conversations we often want to be having in our lives, deep and meaningful conversations. And so this is a lot of conversations. And so this is a lot of conversations. And so this. This is something I've now done with almost 5,000 people. All of our incoming MBA students do this at the University of Chicago now. When I'm out doing public speaking, I do this. You throw a birthday party. I'm going to run your folks through it, Kim. That's what I'm going to do. What I'll do is I'll put up a series of questions that are deep and meaningful. Fans of psychology will recognize these questions as questions that come from Art and Elaine Aaron's fast friends procedure. They're on the deep end of this.
可能无法解释我们对接触和与他人交往的所有过度抵触，但我认为它解释了很大一部分，因为它在我们的脑海中种下了怀疑，而正是这些怀疑驱动了我们的选择。您研究过的其他一些互动例子是什么，参与者认为“我不会喜欢那样”或“那会非常尴尬”，但后来发现它比预期的更有意义？最明显的例子不仅仅是与随机的人交谈以了解他们，而是那些真正让我们与他人建立联系的谈话，即我们生活中经常想要进行的深度和有意义的谈话。这是我目前与近5000人做过的事情。我们芝加哥大学所有新入学的MBA学生现在都这样做。当我在外面做公开演讲时，我也会这样做。你举办生日派对，我会让你的朋友们经历这个过程，金。这就是我要做的。我会提出一系列深刻而有意义的问题。心理学爱好者会认出这些问题来自阿特和伊莱恩·阿伦的“快速朋友”程序。它们处于这个
spectrum questions like, what are you most grateful for in your life? Please tell me about it. Or can you tell me about one of the last times you cried in front of another person? And when I put these questions up on the screen, you can kind of see a Paul just cast over the audience. Like everybody sort of feels a sense of dread that they came to this session today. They kind of looked at the door, wonder if they can escape quickly. But, you know, but there they are. And so I have them go and fill out a survey, tell me how they think this conversation is going to make them feel in a bunch of ways. They then go off and start having the conversation. And once they're started, the problem I have is getting them to come back. That's a,
光谱的深层，比如：你一生中最感激的是什么？请告诉我。或者你能告诉我你最后一次在别人面前哭是什么时候吗？当我把这些问题放在屏幕上时，你可以看到观众中笼罩着一种沉闷的气氛。每个人似乎都感到一种恐惧，后悔今天来参加这个会议。他们有点看向门口，想知道是否能快速逃脱。但是，你知道，他们就在那里。所以我让他们去填一份调查问卷，告诉我他们认为这种谈话会以各种方式让他们感觉如何。然后他们开始进行谈话。一旦开始，我面临的问题就是让他们回来。那是一个，
problem because they don't want to stop talking at that point. And then when they come back, I ask them to tell me how the conversation I actually felt. And the gaps between their beliefs beforehand, how awkward, how much they're going to like their partner, how much of a connection they're going to feel with this person, how much they're going to enjoy the person. The gap between their expectations about those items and their actual experiences are just massive. I mean, they're just enormous. And that's a very big one. And that's one we can also implement, you know, many different ways in our own lives, taking a real interest in another person and asking them meaningful things about themselves and being willing to share something
问题，因为他们那时不想停止谈话。然后当他们回来时，我让他们告诉我谈话实际上感觉如何。他们事先的信念——会有多尴尬、他们会多喜欢对方、他们会与这个人产生多少联系、他们会多享受这个人——与他们实际经历之间的差距是巨大的。我的意思是，它们非常巨大。这是一个非常大的发现。这也是我们可以在自己生活中以多种不同方式实施的事情，即对另一个人产生真正的兴趣，问他们关于他们自己的有意义的事情，并愿意分享一些
meaningful about yourself. Beyond that, there are lots of different kinds of opportunities we have to connect that we've studied, you know, how we connect with somebody, whether we're typing, right, leaning back and typing, keeping our social distance, or leaning in and talking to somebody, talking's better, but people don't tend to realize that in our data. We look at opportunities we have to reach out and lift somebody up, do acts of kindness for them. People underestimate how positively others will respond to acts of kindness, how positive they'll respond when you open up and are honest in your relationship, when you express gratitude, when you ask people for help. Over and over again, we see this misplaced pessimism. Is being outgoing and social
关于你自己的有意义的事情。除此之外，我们研究过很多我们可以建立联系的不同机会，你知道，我们如何与某人建立联系，无论是打字，向后靠着打字，保持社交距离，还是向前倾与某人交谈，交谈更好，但人们在我们的数据中往往没有意识到这一点。我们观察我们有机会接触并提升某人、为他们做善事的时刻。人们低估了他人对善举的回应会多么积极，当你敞开心扉并在关系中诚实、表达感激、向他人寻求帮助时，他们会做出多么积极的回应。我们一次又一次地看到这种错位的悲观情绪。外向和社交
equally good for everyone? I mean, what about people who are really fundamentally introverted? Do they benefit as much as extroverts do? First off, we all vary in lots and lots of different ways. And for sure, some people have an easier time interacting with others than some people do. And the kinds of social behaviors we're talking about vary quite a lot, too. However, Let's just take introversion and extroversion and just focus on that. And there, I think the data are actually pretty crystal clear that introversion and extroversion tends to predict not so much people's experiences once they're in an interaction.
对每个人都同样好吗？我的意思是，那些本质上非常内向的人呢？他们能像外向者那样受益吗？首先，我们所有人在很多方面都有所不同。当然，有些人比其他人更容易与他人互动。我们谈论的社交行为类型也各不相同。然而，让我们只谈内向和外向，专注于这一点。在那里，我认为数据实际上非常清楚，内向和外向往往预测的不是人们一旦进入互动后的体验。
It predicts the choices they make beforehand and the expectations that they have going into these interactions, if anything, a little better than their actual experiences. So extroverts tend to choose to reach out engage with other people a little more often. They're a little more, choose to be a little more assertive in their lives, whereas introverts tend to hold back a little more, keep to themselves a little bit more. The data suggests that that has meaningful effects on how happy we report being in our daily lives, how satisfied we are with our lives. Extroverts tend to report being happier than introverts do. The effects aren't small. They're big correlation between extroversion and
它预测的是他们事先做出的选择以及他们在进入这些互动时所持有的期望，如果说有什么不同的话，这比他们的实际体验预测得更好。所以外向者倾向于选择更频繁地接触和与他人交往。他们在生活中选择更自信一点，而内向者倾向于稍微退缩一点，多保持一点独处。数据表明，这对我们报告在日常生活中有多快乐、对生活有多满意有重大影响。外向者往往报告比内向者更快乐。这种影响并不小。外向与
happiness around the world is in the ballpark of a correlation of 0.5, which is, about as big as the correlation between the heights of fathers and sons. That's huge. Correlation with satisfaction with life is a little smaller but still positive. Point three. And when psychologists ask people, or they measure over the course of their day even, times when we spend with other people are the times we report feeling more positive than times we spend alone. That's true for extroverts and introverts alike. And when psychologists ask people to spend a half hour in an experiment or a day of their life or a week of their life or two weeks, of their lives. There's now a cottage industry of these kinds of experiments when psychologists
世界各地的幸福感之间的相关性大约在0.5左右，这大约相当于父亲和儿子身高之间的相关性。这非常巨大。与生活满意度的相关性稍小，但仍然是正相关的，为0.3。当心理学家询问人们，甚至在他们的一天中进行测量时，我们与他人共度的时间是我们报告感觉比独处时更积极的时间。这对内向者和外向者都适用。当心理学家要求人们在实验中花半小时，或者在他们生活的一天、一周或两周里这样做时。现在有一系列这类实验，当心理学家
ask people to do this, what they generally find is that asking people to act more extroverted lifts people's moods, makes people feel more positive, regardless of how extroverted or introverted you are, as long as you are actually doing it. There's some experiments that find that not everybody follows through on the request to act more extroverted. Introverts might not choose to do that, and then they don't get the mood boost that they would if they actually did those things in the same way that exercise won't make you healthier if you don't do it. Right? It's sort of similar to that. But I think at least when it comes to happiness and positive affect, introverts as well as extroverts can find opportunities to reach out and connect with people that will be surprisingly uplifting for them.
要求人们这样做时，他们通常发现，要求人们表现得更外向会提升人们的情绪，使人们感觉更积极，无论你有多外向或内向，只要你真的去做了。有些实验发现，并非每个人都会执行表现得更外向的要求。内向者可能不会选择这样做，然后他们就不会获得如果他们真的做了那些事情本可以获得的情绪提升，就像如果你不锻炼，锻炼就不会让你更健康一样。对吧？这有点类似。但我认为，至少在幸福感和积极情感方面，内向者和外向者都可以找到接触和与人建立联系的机会，这将给他们带来令人惊讶的振奋。
Fundamentally, why are we so reluctant to talk to strangers? I mean, is it something that's almost genetic that in order to survive, we have to be wary of people we don't know? There may be something to that. I just can't really test that in my experiments. I don't really have any... I mean, I can wave my hands at that kind of story.
从根本上说，为什么我们如此不愿与陌生人交谈？我的意思是，这是否几乎是基因决定的，为了生存，我们必须对不认识的人保持警惕？这可能确实有一定道理。我只是无法在我的实验中真正测试这一点。我真的没有任何……我的意思是，我可以对那种说法挥挥手。
I could also wave my hands at a story where those of us who are the most socially capable were also the most successful. And that actually looks to be the history of human evolution. It's not avoiding strangers. that was our superpower. It was our ability to connect with strangers and bind them to us in ways that enable cooperation that pushed our species forward. It's the reason why our cerebral cortex is three times larger than our nearest primate relatives at chimpanzee because we are built for social stuff.
我也可以对另一种说法挥挥手，即那些社交能力最强的人也是最成功的。这看起来确实是人类进化的历史。不是回避陌生人，那才是我们的超能力。是我们与陌生人建立联系并将他们与我们绑定在一起以实现合作的能力，推动了我们物种的进步。这就是为什么我们的大脑皮层比我们最近的灵长类亲属黑猩猩大三倍的原因，因为我们是为社交而生的。
So I don't think it's wariness that, you know, that was pushing us evolutionarily. I think it was sociality that was. But what I can say is that in any given moment, there are lots of things happening in that moment, the way you interpret that situation, the way you think about how somebody else is going to respond that can explain a lot of our reluctance to do it. It can also then predict variability in your willingness to reach out. So if you think somebody else wants to connect with you, you're much more willing to do this. People don't have any reluctance talking to friends, right? It's strangers because they're uncertain of how that person will respond. That's it. But if you know that
所以我认为在进化上推动我们的不是警惕性。我认为是社交性。但我能说的是，在任何给定的时刻，那一刻发生了很多事情，你解释那种情况的方式，你思考别人会如何回应的方式，可以解释我们很多不愿这样做的原因。它还可以预测你接触意愿的变异性。所以如果你认为别人想和你建立联系，你更愿意这样做。人们与朋友交谈没有任何抵触，对吧？是陌生人，因为他们不确定那个人会如何回应。就是这样。但如果你知道那
person would respond nicely to you. You've heard they're a nice person. You know they have some connection with you so you have some reason to think they'll be interested in talking to you. You'll happily talk to them. Or if you think about being warm and friendly, you're more willing to reach out and engage with other people than if you sit and focus on your competence. If you know, you'll have something to talk about with somebody, you're more likely to reach out, right? So there's a lot of uncertainty that comes from what we talked about before, failing to realize kind of the responsiveness that happens in interaction that pulls us together, and excessive focus on our competency rather than on how we'll be received
个人会很好地回应你。你听说他们是个好人。你知道他们和你有一些联系，所以你有理由认为他们会有兴趣和你交谈。你会很高兴地和他们交谈。或者如果你考虑表现得温暖和友好，你比坐着专注于自己的能力更愿意接触和与他人交往。如果你知道你会和某人有话可聊，你更有可能伸出援手，对吧？所以有很多不确定性来自于我们之前谈到的，未能意识到互动中发生的响应性将我们拉在一起，以及过度关注我们的能力而不是我们被接收的方式，
if we just reach out to other people in friendly ways, that I think can explain an awful lot of this variability day-to-day. And then there's also a lot of individual learning. So not everybody is as miscalibrated as others. People who spend a lot of time talking to people don't get this wrong, right? It's avoidance that creates the mistakes. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Epley about small talk and deep talk
如果我们只是以友好的方式接触他人，我认为这可以解释这种日常变异的很大一部分。而且还有很多个人学习。所以并非每个人都像其他人那样校准错误。花很多时间与人交谈的人不会犯这种错误，对吧？是回避造成了错误。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与埃普利博士谈谈闲聊和深度谈话，
and about why we often find deep conversations more rewarding and less awkward than we expect to. This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg.
以及为什么我们经常发现深度谈话比我们预期的更有意义且更不尴尬。今年春天，牛仔布变得更柔软、更轻盈。隆重推出Old Navy的垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤，一种随你而动的新版型。这是你夏天想要牛仔裤感觉的一切。轻松、透气，且毫不费力地酷。这种版型创造了自然的运动感，阔腿设计感觉现代，而不会让人感到压抑。此外，还有那种标志性的“等等，这个价格？”时刻。Old Navy垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤。
Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.
嘿，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，代表Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想：如果呢？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“如果”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问Wayfair.ca。
Wayfair, every style, every home. Now, you've also looked at the difference between small talk and deep talk. And people will say that they hate small talk and that they're hesitant to talk about deeper subjects, especially with people they don't know well. Why is this and what have you found as you've looked at this? So it's a similar phenomena that we see in talking with strangers or reaching out to express gratitude is you're uncertain about how the other person will respond. You're not sure that they will respond positively. And as a result, you're reluctant to reach out and engage with them out of some fear that they might not want to talk about this or might not respond back to you in as honest a way as you open up to them. In our data, in our experiments, like our deep conversations that I described earlier, we find that people think that they're more interested in the content of what they're
Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。现在，您也研究了闲聊和深度谈话之间的区别。人们会说他们讨厌闲聊，并且他们对谈论更深层的话题感到犹豫，特别是与他们不太熟悉的人。为什么会这样，当您研究这一点时，您发现了什么？这与我们与陌生人交谈或伸出援手表达感激时看到的现象类似，你不确定对方会如何回应。你不确定他们会做出积极的回应。结果，你因为担心他们可能不想谈论这个，或者可能不会像你向他们敞开心扉那样诚实地回应你，而对接触和与他们交往感到犹豫。在我们的数据中，在我们的实验中，比如我之前描述的深度谈话，我们发现人们认为他们对所分享内容的兴趣
going to share than the other person will be. So that's one. If you're not, if I'm going to tell you about this thing that's really meaningful, but I think you're not really going to care about it, that's going to be a hard conversation. After the conversation, what people find is that once they were in the conversation, the other person was interested in it because that's the way conversation generally works. But that doubt about how social the other person will be, will they respond positively back to me, that's what creates the barrier to those deep conversations. A few years ago, the then-surgeon general, Vivek Murthy, said that Americans are experienced an epidemic of loneliness. Do you agree with that? And if so, how might your research be
比对方会有的兴趣要大。所以这是第一点。如果你不……如果我要告诉你这件非常有意义的事情，但我认为你不会真正关心它，那将是一场艰难的谈话。谈话结束后，人们发现一旦他们进入了谈话，对方确实对此感兴趣，因为这就是谈话通常的工作方式。但那种对对方社交意愿的怀疑——他们会积极地回应我吗——正是造成这些深度谈话障碍的原因。几年前，当时的卫生局局长维韦克·默西说，美国人正在经历一场孤独的流行病。您同意这一点吗？如果是这样，您的研究可能与
related to that belief? Whether you call it an epidemic or not is a little bit about semantics. There is no doubt that loneliness has been on the rise for decades now. So, on the gold standard measure of social isolation or loneliness, the UCLA loneliness scale, which is a 21 item scale that psychologists have been using back to 1974, which was the year I was born. I'm 51 years old. If you look at that measure,
那个信念有什么关系？你称之为流行病还是其他，这有点语义问题。毫无疑问，孤独感几十年来一直在上升。所以，在社会孤立或孤独的黄金标准衡量指标——UCLA孤独感量表上，这是一个心理学家自1974年（我出生的那一年）以来一直在使用的21项量表。我今年51岁。如果你看那个指标，
it has been increasing scores among college students, have been increasing steadily since 1974. There's not a hockey stick upturn in recent years. You do see that in some other data, but on this gold standard, you don't. But on this UCLA loneliness scale, research shows it's gone up by about half a standard deviation. And that's a big effect. So the way I write about it in a little more social is I translate that into another
它一直在增加。大学生中的得分自1974年以来一直在稳步上升。近年来并没有出现曲棍球棒式的激增。你在其他一些数据中确实看到了这一点，但在这一黄金标准上，你没有看到。但在UCLA孤独感量表上，研究表明它上升了大约半个标准差。这是一个很大的效应。所以我写在《多一点社交》中的方式是，我把它翻译成另一个
variable that you might be able to understand, like the height of men. So it turns out a half standard deviation increase in the height of men would account to about three inches, at least in the United States, would be about a three inch increase, which would mean that, you know, my kids born today would on average. be three inches taller than I am, which you would, you know, kids born the year that I was in 1974. You would notice that. Like you would notice that kids these days seem awful dark tall, right? You would get that. And so that is big. And I do think our research is very relevant to this because data clearly suggests that we are avoiding other people more now than we have in the past.
你可能能够理解的变量，比如男性的身高。事实证明，男性身高增加半个标准差大约相当于三英寸，至少在美国是这样，大约是三英寸的增长，这意味着，你知道，今天出生的我的孩子平均会比我高三英寸，你会，你知道，1974年我出生那年出生的孩子。你会注意到这一点。就像你会注意到现在的孩子看起来非常高，对吧？你会明白的。所以这很大。而且我确实认为我们的研究与此非常相关，因为数据清楚地表明，我们现在比过去更多地回避他人。
some of it, you know, I think for most of human history, social connection wasn't as much of a choice you made. You were around other people. You had to interact with them because you had to get things done. You didn't really have much other choice. Now, the thoughts we have about how somebody might respond to us, those expectations that can cause us to choose to reach out or not, those matter more because we can make the choice to avoid people in a way that maybe we never have before in human, history. At least we're increasingly able to avoid people. You can get up, Kim, on any given morning, you know, order your breakfast online, have it delivered to your door, get your groceries for lunch, right? And, you know, work on your computer all day. Be very productive, you know, get your dinner at night from, you know, some door delivery service, never have to talk to anybody, pull up your Netflix and chill all through the evening and never sing a soul, right? Never see a single person. And you could do that for day after day after day if you wanted to. There's a recent paper released by Matthias Meal, who's at the University of Arizona, who has been for decades now
其中一些，你知道，我认为在人类历史的大部分时间里，社会联系并不是你做出的选择。你就在其他人身边。你必须与他们互动，因为你必须完成事情。你真的没有太多其他选择。现在，我们关于别人可能如何回应我们的想法，那些可能导致我们选择接触与否的期望，这些变得更重要了，因为我们可以做出回避人的选择，这在人类历史上可能从未有过。至少我们越来越能够回避人。金，你可以在任何一个早晨起床，你知道，在线订购早餐，送到门口，买午餐的杂货，对吧？而且，你知道，整天在电脑上工作。非常高效，你知道，晚上从，你知道，某种送餐服务订晚餐，永远不必和任何人说话，打开Netflix，整个晚上都在放松，永远看不到一个人，对吧？永远看不到一个人。如果你愿意，你可以日复一日地这样做。最近有一篇由亚利桑那大学的马蒂亚斯·米尔发表的论文，他几十年来一直在
monitoring how much people talk in their daily lives. And he just released a paper that found, where he found, if you just looked at how much people were speaking, they're speaking on average 300 fewer words a day, 3338, 338 on average a day. In 2019, then they were in 2007, right? You see that decreased in the amount of time we spend with other people in the American time use survey too. We're spending more time alone in front of the TV by ourselves. And I think a lot of that does come from these moment-to-moment choices we make to avoid other people, and you could choose differently, moment-to-moment. Do we know that this has happened? in other countries as well. I mean, we're very privileged in this country and we can build our
监测人们在日常生活中说话的频率。他刚刚发表了一篇论文，发现如果你只看人们说话的量，他们平均每天少说300个词，平均每天少说338个词。2019年比2007年，对吧？你在美国时间使用调查中也看到了我们与他人共度时间的减少。我们花更多时间独自在电视机前。我认为这很大程度上确实来自于我们为了回避他人而做出的时刻选择，而你可以时刻做出不同的选择。我们知道这在其他国家也发生了吗？我的意思是，我们在美国非常优越，我们可以建造我们的
McMansions and have, you know, a gym and the big screen TV and all the reasons why we wouldn't go out. But a lot of other places, folks don't have that. No, a lot of other places do not. Absolutely. And in fact, my colleague here at the University of Chicago, Thomas Talhelm, is a cross-cultural psychologist, and he studies sociality around the world, measuring individualism and collectivism. But one of the things that he's focused on in his measures is how often people talk to strangers just routinely or how willing they are talk to strangers.
豪宅，拥有健身房和大屏幕电视，以及我们不出去的所有理由。但在许多其他地方，人们没有这些。不，许多其他地方没有。绝对没有。事实上，我在芝加哥大学的同事托马斯·塔尔赫姆是一位跨文化心理学家，他研究世界各地的社交性，衡量个人主义和集体主义。但他关注的指标之一是人们在日常生活中与陌生人交谈的频率，或者他们与陌生人交谈的意愿。
And there's meaningful variability around the world in this. The U.S. is kind of in the middle on this. There are some places that are much more social, some places that are much less social, at least in the talking to strangers part. We don't actually know where all of this comes from. at least I will say, I don't know, and I've looked at this very, very hard, where all of this variability comes from. I think a lot of it comes from our expectations about how other people
世界各地在这方面存在有意义的变异。美国在这方面处于中间位置。有些地方社交性强得多，有些地方社交性弱得多，至少在与陌生人交谈的部分是这样。我们实际上不知道这一切来自哪里。至少我会说，我不知道，而且我非常非常努力地研究过这一点，所有这些变异来自哪里。我认为很大程度上来自于我们对其他人
will respond. In Finland, for instance, people don't talk to each other a lot there unless they're nude with each other once a week and a sauna on a Friday, which is a thing in Finland. They love their saunas. And there they have really deep and meaningful conversations, you know, once a week or however often they get together in their communities to do this. It's a great thing. thing. But outside of that, it's impolite or rude to talk to, talk to folks. We have some of that here in the U.S. too. One of the reasons when we ran experiments on the trains and buses and cabs here in Chicago that people didn't want to talk to a stranger was because they thought the other person didn't want to talk to them, so it would be rude, right, to try that. But there are other
将如何回应的期望。例如，在芬兰，人们在那里不怎么交谈，除非他们每周一次在周五的桑拿房里赤身裸体地在一起，这是芬兰的一件事。他们热爱他们的桑拿。在那里，他们每周一次或无论他们多久聚在一起做这件事时，都会进行非常深刻和有意义的谈话。这是一件很棒的事情。但在那之外，与人交谈是不礼貌或粗鲁的。我们在美国也有一些这种情况。我们在芝加哥的火车、公共汽车和出租车上进行实验时，人们不想与陌生人交谈的原因之一是他们认为对方不想和他们说话，所以尝试这样做会很粗鲁，对吧？但还有其他
places you go in the world. If you're on a train in Spain, you're going to have a hard time not talking to folks there. And my belief is that this comes from differences on our expectations about how others will respond and what's appropriate in these contexts, not from actual differences in experiences of social connection, right? I think everyone around the world values love and connection
你去世界上的地方。如果你在西班牙的火车上，你很难不和那里的人交谈。我的信念是，这来自于我们对他人将如何回应以及在这些背景下什么是适当的期望的差异，而不是来自于社会联系体验的实际差异，对吧？我认为世界各地的人都重视爱和联系，
and being, you know, having friends in their lives and people who they feel like they can trust and feel connected to. But we do not yet know where variability in these expectations comes from around the world other than from just the fact of avoidance and we don't necessarily know where that comes. That is the next 15 years of my work, Kim,
并且，你知道，在他们的生活中拥有朋友，以及他们觉得可以信任并感到与之相连的人。但我们还不知道世界各地这些期望的变异来自哪里，除了仅仅是回避的事实，我们也不一定知道这来自哪里。这是我未来15年的工作，金，
and that will be my next book, set to hit the stands in 2041. Well, let me ask you more about our modern life, different forms of communications that we're engaging in now, whether that's Zoom or texting. How does that compare to face-to-face communications in terms of the quality of connection that gets created?
那将是我的下一本书，定于2041年上架。好吧，让我多问您一些关于我们现代生活的问题，我们现在正在参与的不同交流形式，无论是Zoom还是发短信。就创造的联系质量而言，这与面对面的交流相比如何？
I mean, a lot of people, you know, maybe you talk to your mom once a week on the phone. If you're texting your mother, are you getting the same jolt of, you know, whatever goodness that you would be getting if you spoke face to face? Yeah, probably not, although we haven't studied moms. So that's maybe an important, that's maybe an important caveat here. But we do know that when people reach out and reconnect with old friends, they feel more connected when they talk than when they type. We know that when people talk to strangers, they feel more connected when they talk to the stranger than when they type to the stranger. The voice, it turns out, carries a lot of, carries a lot of cues
我的意思是，很多人，你知道，也许你每周和妈妈通一次电话。如果你是在给妈妈发短信，你是否能获得像面对面交谈那样，你知道，那种满足感？是的，可能不会，尽管我们还没有专门研究过妈妈们。所以这可能是一个重要的，这可能是一个重要的前提。但我们确实知道，当人们主动联系并与老朋友重新建立联系时，他们交谈时比打字时感觉更亲近。我们知道，当人们与陌生人交谈时，他们交谈时比打字时感觉与陌生人更亲近。事实证明，声音承载了许多，承载了许多线索
that reveal your thoughts, your feelings, your emotions, that you are a thinking person. The act of conversation itself, live, vocal conversation itself tends to pull people together in ways that monotone text does not. Those are pretty sizable effects. And yet we find in our research, then when people anticipate how they'll feel at the end of a conversation. They don't anticipate differences between talking and typing unless they compare the two directly against each other. Then they often recognize that talking will feel better than typing. But in one experiment where we did this, I'm at Kumar, who's now at the University of Delaware, and I found that when they were reaching back to old friends, they recognized they'd feel more connected if they talked than if they typed
这些线索揭示了你的思想、你的感受、你的情绪，表明你是一个有思想的人。对话本身，即时的、口头的对话本身往往能以单调的文字无法做到的方式将人们拉近。这些影响相当显著。然而，我们在研究中发现，当人们预判对话结束时的感受时，他们并不会预判到交谈和打字之间的差异，除非他们直接将两者进行比较。那时，他们通常会意识到交谈比打字感觉更好。但在我们做过的一个实验中，我和现在在特拉华大学的库马尔发现，当他们联系老朋友时，他们意识到如果交谈，会比打字感觉更亲近
to their old friend. But they also thought it would be more awkward if they talked than if they typed. So when we asked people to choose, how would you like to reconnect? Most people, two-thirds of people, said, I'd rather type than talk. But when we actually then had them do this, it turns out they did feel more connected when they talked, but they did not feel any more awkward. So this cue that people were using to avoid a voice conversation was misleading and it would have led a lot of people to avoid what was otherwise a more satisfying verbal conversation. So when you've got to change, pick up the phone and actually talk using your face parts, using your actual mouth parts, rather than your thumbs, it'll be a better conversation.
对他们的老朋友来说。但他们也认为，如果交谈，会比打字更尴尬。所以当我们让人们选择时，你想如何重新建立联系？大多数人，三分之二的人说，我宁愿打字也不愿交谈。但当我们真正让他们这样做时，结果发现他们交谈时确实感觉更亲近，但并没有感到更尴尬。所以人们用来避免语音对话的这个线索是误导性的，它会导致许多人避免本可以更令人满意的口头对话。所以当你需要改变时，拿起电话，用你的面部器官，用你真正的嘴部器官，而不是用你的拇指去交谈，这会是一次更好的对话。
You know, what I see is a lot of people will, they'll send you a text saying, can you talk now? I mean, back in the day before you could text, you just pick up the phone and call somebody and either they answered or they didn't. But, you know, is everybody doing this now? Is this we have to make sure that somebody's willing to talk to us? Well, you don't have to. You don't have to.
你知道，我看到很多人会，他们会给你发短信说，你现在能说话吗？我的意思是，在短信出现之前，你只是拿起电话打给某人，要么他们接听，要么不接听。但是，你知道，现在每个人都这样做吗？这是我们必须确保某人愿意和我们交谈吗？嗯，你不必这样做。你不必这样做。
I'm not sure, you know, I think ultimately if it ends up in a phone call, I don't want to be overly negative about, you know, modern technology. It allows us to do amazing things. It's an awesome tool. I was flying home from New York City this morning. I was sitting on the airplane. I got to see my 10-year-old daughter that morning for a quick FaceTime call. And that was lovely before we took off, right? And I could text my wife when I got in and just landed, send her some emoji kisses and feel connected to her in that moment when I couldn't talk to her. So it's, I don't want to be overly negative about text, but I will say, you know, when you can do either easily, pick up the phone. It'll be better. It'll be better. And so when there's no additional cost to it, give it a try, and if somebody can't answer, of course, you know, they don't have to.
我不确定，你知道，我认为最终如果它演变成一个电话，我不想对现代科技过于消极。它让我们能够做令人惊奇的事情。这是一个很棒的工具。我今天早上从纽约市飞回家。我坐在飞机上。那天早上我能和我的10岁女儿进行了一次简短的FaceTime通话。那在起飞前很美好，对吧？当我到达并刚刚降落时，我可以给我的妻子发短信，给她发一些表情符号吻，并在我无法和她交谈的那一刻感到与她相连。所以，我不想对短信过于消极，但我会说，你知道，当你能轻松做任何一种时，拿起电话。这会更好。这会更好。所以当没有额外成本时，试一试，如果有人无法接听，当然，你知道，他们不必接听。
But, you know, I don't see the texting can be a very good way to establish a connection. It's not necessarily the best way to create the optimal connection. But if you use it a place to start, that's okay. How has your research changed the way you live your own life? It has been foundational. I really remember when I got off the train that morning when I talked to the woman in the red hat, I thought, I do this a lot.
但是，你知道，我不认为短信是一种建立联系的好方法。它不一定是创造最佳联系的最佳方式。但如果你把它当作一个起点，那没关系。你的研究如何改变了你自己的生活方式？它是基础性的。我真的记得那天早上我下火车时，当我与那个戴红帽子的女人交谈时，我想，我经常这样做。
I would never have called myself a horribly introverted person, but, you know, I was horribly terrified of stage fright when I was younger when I was in grad school, terrified of public speaking then, nervous at conferences to talk with people. You know, had my head down. walking around a lot. I was a college football player in a Division III college football player at St. Olaf, um, yeah. And, and so, you know, I was kind of rough and kind of quiet, I would say, at times. I could be, avoidant, like to spend a lot of time in the woods. And it, this has really
我绝不会称自己是一个极其内向的人，但是，你知道，我年轻时在研究生院时非常害怕舞台恐惧症，那时害怕公开演讲，在会议上与人交谈时感到紧张。你知道，我低着头。走来走去很多。我曾是一名大学橄榄球运动员，在圣奥拉夫学院的一所三级大学橄榄球运动员，嗯，是的。所以，你知道，我有时有点粗鲁，有点安静，我会说。我可能会，回避，喜欢在树林里花很多时间。这真的
changed the way I live, live my life kind of top to bottom. And a few fundamental things. One is I take an interest in other people in a way I never did before, and to a degree I never did before. because I know how interesting anybody can be. Bill Nye, famous science guy, Cornell grad. I got my PhD from there, go big red. Bill Nye, once famous, he said, everyone you ever meet knows something you don't. He's right about that, right?
改变了我生活的方式，从头到尾。有几件基本的事情。第一，我以一种我以前从未有过的方式，并且以一种我以前从未有过的程度对其他人产生兴趣。因为我知道任何人都可以多么有趣。比尔·奈，著名的科学人，康奈尔大学毕业生。我从那里获得了博士学位，加油大红。比尔·奈，曾经很有名，他说，你遇到的每个人都知道一些你不知道的事情。他是对的，对吧？
I also have learned from our data that people are exceptionally kind, can be very kind if you reach out and give them the opportunity to. So I give people the opportunity to do that. It's made a difference in how I interact, with strangers, my train rides are almost never silent anymore. I've turned tons of strangers into acquaintances, even if just for a moment, you know, just for a little bit, made those moments
我还从我们的数据中了解到，人们非常善良，如果你主动联系并给他们机会，他们可以非常善良。所以我给人们机会这样做。这改变了我与陌生人互动的方式，我的火车旅程几乎不再沉默了。我已经把无数的陌生人变成了熟人，即使只是片刻，你知道，只是为了那么一点点，让那些时刻
better. My friendships have gotten stronger because I'm more open. I think about others more, reach out a little more often. When I know somebody is in need of support, I don't think I got to fix something. I reach out and tell my thinking about you. I care about you. And I will reach out again tomorrow and connect with you then. And I'll stop by and take them down to coffee. Whatever. I will, I reach out more often. In my marriage, I would say I'm more open and honest. I'm less defensive in conversation. Reach out, I think have better conversations with my wife.
变得更好。我的友谊变得更牢固了，因为我更开放了。我更多地考虑别人，更经常地主动联系。当我得知某人需要支持时，我不认为我必须解决什么问题。我主动联系并告诉他们我在想你。我在乎你。明天我会再次联系你，那时再和你交流。我会顺便去带他们去喝咖啡。无论什么。我会，我更经常地主动联系。在我的婚姻中，我会说我更开放和诚实。我在对话中不那么防御。主动联系，我认为与我的妻子有更好的对话。
And it's even affected some major decisions that I've been involved with in our lives. We lost a baby 10 years ago this year. July 11th, 2016, six months into my wife's pregnancy, our daughter who we named Sophie, had Down syndrome. We were prepared to go forward. We're very excited for this baby. We'd already had four other children adopted to over the years, but this was going to be a whole new adventure in our lives.
它甚至影响了我参与生活中的一些重大决定。我们今年失去了十年前的一个孩子。2016年7月11日，在我妻子怀孕六个月时，我们取名为苏菲的女儿患有唐氏综合症。我们准备继续前进。我们对这个孩子非常兴奋。我们多年来已经收养了其他四个孩子，但这将是我们生活中一个全新的冒险。
And when we lost her, it was super painful. And it was about a year after that, when Jen, my wife, she was sitting in the sunroom one morning, and I asked her if she would, you know, if she might consider adopting a child again. Because we were ready to go. We could maybe do this again. And she asked me,
当我们失去她时，那非常痛苦。大约一年后，当我的妻子简，她一天早上坐在阳光房里，我问她是否愿意，你知道，她是否会考虑再次收养一个孩子。因为我们准备好了。我们也许可以再做一次。她问我，
it turns out we can adopt a child with Down syndrome. Would you be willing to do that? Could we consider adopting a child with Down syndrome? And my head was not in that place at that time. That's not where my mind was. But at that time, as every researcher who listens to your podcast can attest, their data enters into their thinking at times. And this comes up for me all the time.
结果我们可以收养一个患有唐氏综合症的孩子。你愿意这样做吗？我们可以考虑收养一个患有唐氏综合症的孩子吗？当时我的头脑不在那个地方。那不是我当时的想法。但当时，正如每一位听你播客的研究人员所能证明的那样，他们的数据有时会进入他们的思考。这对我来说一直都会出现。
It lives in my head all the time. And right there, I felt it was just clear to me. My wife was giving me that the choice we all have to reach out and engage with somebody or to hold back and avoid them. And I'd seen thousands and thousands and thousands of data points of people being overly pessimistic about how well it would go when they reached out to connect with another person. And I realized that in that moment, I was doing exactly the same thing. And it gave me some courage to say, yeah, we can do this.
它一直活在我的脑海里。就在那一刻，我感到它对我来说很清楚。我的妻子给了我那个选择，我们都有选择去主动联系并与某人接触，或者退缩并回避他们。我见过成千上万个数据点，显示人们在主动联系他人时对结果过于悲观。我意识到在那一刻，我正在做完全相同的事情。这给了我一些勇气说，是的，我们可以做到。
We can do this. And, you know, because Jen and I were in such a good place and she was on board, we were on board with us together, it gave me the courage to go forward. We brought Lindsay, our amazing 10-year-old daughter home eight years ago now. We adapted her in 2018 from China, and she is just all shades of fabulous. Not always easy. Hard, hard raising child at times, of course, one with intellectual disabilities, too. But holy cow, has she blessed our lives in ways that I just never could have imagined. So it is profoundly changed my life in ways both moment to moment day to day and massive. That's a great story.
我们可以做到。而且，你知道，因为简和我在一个很好的状态，她也同意，我们一起同意，这给了我前进的勇气。我们八年前把我们了不起的10岁女儿琳赛带回家了。我们在2018年从中国收养了她，她简直是太棒了。并不总是容易。有时抚养孩子很难，很难，当然，还有一个有智力障碍的孩子。但天哪，她以我从未想象过的方式祝福了我们的生活。所以它深刻地改变了我的生活，无论是从片刻到片刻，从一天到一天，还是巨大的改变。那是一个伟大的故事。
Well, let me close by asking you what you're working on now. I mean, what are the big questions that you're trying to answer today? So I'm interested in, one, why is it we don't learn this? Why don't we figure this out over time? Avoidance is one, but Stavatier, one of my wonderful postdocs, who's now at the University of Wisconsin-Madison, and I learned recently. We just published a paper in APA's Journal of Personality and Social Psychology Journal.
好吧，让我最后问你现在正在研究什么。我的意思是，你今天试图回答的大问题是什么？所以我感兴趣的是，第一，为什么我们学不会这一点？为什么我们随着时间的推移没有弄明白这一点？回避是一个，但斯塔瓦蒂尔，我的一位出色的博士后，现在在威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校，我们最近学到了。我们刚刚在APA的《人格与社会心理学杂志》上发表了一篇论文。
We learned that even after people have a conversation that goes well, an interaction that goes well, they do learn from that. They think another conversation would be great, but a couple weeks after that, when they go back to have another conversation, all of the learning that they had two weeks ago is gone. And now they're right back where they were. So the misunderstanding seems persistent, and that's interesting to me. I'm also interested in the question we talked about before,
我们了解到，即使在人们进行了一次顺利的对话，一次顺利的互动之后，他们确实从中学习到了。他们认为另一次对话会很棒，但几周后，当他们回去进行另一次对话时，他们两周前学到的所有东西都消失了。现在他们又回到了原来的位置。所以这种误解似乎是持续存在的，这对我来说很有趣。我也对我们之前讨论的问题感兴趣，
which is variability around the world. Sociality looks different around the world in lots of ways. I think the effects we're documenting have a fundamental quality to admit, you know, everywhere on the planet it's possible for people to be overly pessimistic about how their interactions will go. to the extent that varies around the world, I don't know, to the extent that matters and explaining differences in sociality, I'm not sure yet. We're just starting on that. We certainly have looked at variance in expectations within cultures, people who are more pessimistic are actually more mistaken.
也就是世界各地的差异。社交在世界各地以许多方式看起来不同。我认为我们记录的影响具有一种基本的品质，你知道，在地球上的任何地方，人们都有可能对他们的互动结果过于悲观。至于这在世界各地有多大差异，我不知道，至于这在解释社交差异方面有多重要，我还不确定。我们才刚刚开始研究。我们当然研究了文化内部期望的差异，那些更悲观的人实际上更错误。
And my bet is that's going on around the world too, but we don't know yet. So that's the other place that I'm going. And so I would say those are the two big things. And then we're also, we've also gotten interested thirdly and how costly this might be. How much time are we actually choosing not to spend with other people that we could? How much different could our lives actually be if we were calibrated about how others would respond when we reach out to them? So we're starting to think about this in more practical terms in that way. And what I'm confident about, though, is that new ideals will keep coming up about this because they do almost every week in conversations as my grad students.
我敢打赌世界各地也是这样，但我们还不知道。所以这是我正在研究的另一个方向。所以我会说这是两件大事。然后我们还，我们还对第三点感兴趣，即这可能有多大的代价。我们实际上选择了多少时间不与我们可以相处的其他人在一起？如果我们对别人在回应我们时会如何反应有准确的判断，我们的生活会有多大的不同？所以我们正开始以更实际的方式思考这个问题。但我有信心的是，关于这一点会不断出现新的想法，因为它们几乎每周都在我的研究生对话中出现。
Dr. Epley, I want to thank you for joining me today. I hope we have encouraged our listeners to maybe reach out and talk to a stranger. Thank you, Kim. I hope so too. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
埃普利博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。我希望我们鼓励了我们的听众也许去主动联系并与陌生人交谈。谢谢你，金。我也希望如此。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association,
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢你的收听。对于美国心理学会，
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。